we're twisting arms with threatening
as unemployment hovers around 10% and
any sort of recovery seems to be forever
in a day away think about this the one
part of the economy that's going
gangbusters during the Great Recession
is government work according to recovery
gov most of the 595 thousand jobs that
have been created or saved by the
stimulus package have been in the public
sector with over two-thirds going to
education but far from stimulating us
into any sort of recovery public sector
employees are killing the economy for at
least three reasons federal workers make
about $8,000 more in straight salary
than their counterparts in the private
sector and they make about $30,000 more
in health pension and other fringe
benefits state local workers make
comparable wages to private sector
counterparts but they make significantly
more when benefits are factored in
the private sector has cut over eight
million jobs since the recession started
in December 2007 over the same period
the public sector saw a net gain of at
least a hundred thousand jobs the
private sector adjusted changes in
consumer demand by hiring and firing
more people the public sector just adds
and adds workers because it's not
subject to the same sort of bottom-line
pressures take a look at California
where the teachers union has spent more
than 211 million dollars over the past
decade on Elections
we're twisting arms that's more than
twice as much as the next biggest vendor
which was another union as a result 40%
of government spending in California
must by law go to education and in the
past ten years taxpayer contributions to
the state pension system have increased
by two thousand percent and that sort of
explosive growth is just getting started
for the first time ever a majority of
union members are now in the public
sector that means they'll be lobbying
state houses and legislators even more
for the sorts of big mandatory raises
and absolute job security that workers
in the private sector can only dream of
because the public sector gets its money
from taxpayers everything it gains means
less money for the rest of us to invest
to pay workers or to save and with the
federal government in most states
already deeply in the red it's time to
cut public sector payrolls and return
more revenue to the private sector that
will generate more economic growth which
will help end the recession sooner than
paying higher taxes for these government
salaries for Reason TV I'm Nicholas bee